I've done a bunch of videos now
on inflation and deflation
and how they can be impacted
by capacity utilization.
And the traditional notion of
capacity utilization, and this
is what my brain does when
someone mentions it, is I
think of industrial capacity
utilization.
I imagine factories.
And when people say low
utilization, I imagine idle
factories, and when high
utilization, I imagine
factories that are running at
three shifts and things are
moving feverishly.
But in a service-based economy
like we have here in the U.S.
and like we have in a lot of
Western societies, most of our
real capacity for what we
produce, or our GDP, is
service based, because we're
a service-based economy.
And if you think about it,
industrial capacity
utilization, it matters, but
it matters much more to
manufacturing-based economy.
In a service-based economy,
the best measure of
utilization really
is unemployment.
And I guess we could say
the best measure of
underutilization is
unemployment.
With that said, I think it's
really important to have a
deeper understanding of how
unemployment is measured and
how it's thought about from
the Government, and the
numbers you hear on CNN, what
they really mean in terms of
the real unemployment picture.
And most of these charts,
actually all of these charts
that I have in this video, I
got from Mike Shedlock, who
runs the Global Economic
Analysis blog.
And I had a conversation with
him on Friday and he pointed
out some really interesting
things.
That's what I really want to
cover, and I think it'll give
us a good general view of
unemployment and give us some
clues as to what's going
on right now.
But I encourage you
to read his blog.
He goes by Mish, and he tells
people that the best way to
find his blog is to just do a
search on Google for Mish.
And he does a lot of this, where
he looks at the economic
data, but he goes several levels
deeper than anyone
really would go, especially
on TV.
But that's what you really have
to do to really discern
what matters.
And I want to give him full
credit because he really is
who pointed out a lot of this
to me, but I think it's very
instructive to the capacity
utilization and
inflation-deflation argument
that I've been making.
So right here I have a
screenshot from the Bureau Of
Labor Statistics and you
could go there, just do
a search for them.
And what most people don't
realize is, just like on the
money supply, you have different
measures of money
supply, you also have different
measures of
unemployment.
And the number that you hear
reported, at least since 1994,
is U-3, and that's where
we'll start.
That's kind of the official
rate of unemployment.
I know you can't read
this properly.
My screen capture software
doesn't do
well with this font.
But U-3 is total unemployed as
a percent of the civilian
labor force.
So it's very important to
realize what they consider
unemployed and what they
consider the labor force.
They consider you unemployed
if you don't have a job and
you have looked for work
in the past four weeks.
And this is a really
important point.
It really is important to think
about it relative to
everything else I'll go
over in this video.
Because we've probably had times
in our life where we
considered ourselves unemployed
or we considered
someone else unemployed, but
they had maybe gotten dejected
and stopped looking
a little bit or
decided to take a break.
It's important to realize, in
the numbers that we hear from
the Government, they don't count
as part of the civilian
labor force.
Well, let's say, you stop
looking for a job for five
weeks, because you wanted to
take a break and maybe redo
your resume for awhile, so
you're kind of passively
looking for a job.
The Government no longer
considers you part of the
labor force and you're not
included in that number.
They do have broader numbers
that do include that.
And I think that's important,
because we're actually going
to study the difference between
the different numbers.
U-4 is total unemployed.
So it's the number up here, plus
discouraged workers, as a
percent of the civilian
labor force,
plus discouraged workers.
So they're going to add
the discouraged
workers to the numerator.
Let me do this in a
different color.
Before you had-- this
is the standard one.
You have unemployed over
employed plus unemployed, as
defined-- and when we say
unemployed, it's someone who
doesn't have a job, but you've
looked for a job in the last
four weeks.
U-4 is now-- let me do it
in a different color.
It is unemployed plus
discouraged over employed plus
unemployed plus discouraged
workers.
And their definition of
discouraged workers-- I just
talked about people who haven't
looked or actively
looked for a job in more than
five weeks or actually more
than four weeks.
You're considered discouraged if
you give a reason for that,
and you say, well, I just
haven't looked for it, because
I'm discouraged, because I don't
think there are jobs for
what I want to do anymore, so
that's the reason why haven't
looked for it.
And that's when you get included
into this bucket.
And then U-5 is that same thing,
but what they do is
they add other marginally
attached workers.
And the difference between a
discouraged worker and a
marginally attached worker, a
discouraged worker gives the
economic reason.
They say I haven't looked for
a job in the past five weeks
because I just think
it's impossible.
I want to work but it's just
impossible find a job as an
accountant or an engineer
anymore.
While a marginally attached
worker also says I haven't
looked for a job in the last
five weeks, but they don't say
it's because they think the
economy is making it
impossible.
It could just be that they're--
I don't know--
depressed generally or they
don't want to-- it could be a
whole set of reasons.
The important thing is that on
the survey that the Bureau Of
Labor Statistics conducts, that
they don't literally give
that argument that the only
reason that they're not
looking for it is economic
reasons, and then they'll be
put into the marginally
attached
workers and that's U-5.
And then U-6 is really
interesting because it
includes all of these
above, but it
actually shifts some people.
So in U-5 you would add
marginally attached to the
denominator there.
In U-6 what you do is you have
total unemployed plus all
marginally attached workers plus
total employed part-time
for economic reasons as a
percent of the civilian labor
force, plus all marginally
attached workers.
So the important thing here
is, plus total employed
part-time for economic
reasons.
That's key, so the denominator
doesn't change anymore, but
this unemployed number is
going to get bigger.
Because there's some part of
the employed population who
are not working 40 hours a week,
or they're not working
as much as they want to work,
or they're not maybe working
in even the field they
want to work.
Maybe instead of working as an
engineer, they're working 20
hours a week at the local
bookstore or at Starbuck's,
and these people are
included in U-6.
And the reason why I want to
really highlight that, and
Mish pointed this out to me,
is that this is increasing
much faster than this.
And we'll think a little bit
about why that's happening and
what conclusions we can take.
These are the numbers straight
from the Bureau Of Labor
Statistics.
I know this screen right here is
really hard to see, but if
you look at March 2008, the U-3
number was 5.2% and the
U-6 was 9.3%.
So the difference between
the two is about 4.1%.
But if you go to the most recent
month, the standard
unemployment number is 8.5%,
but the U-6, the one that
includes the discouraged
workers, the marginally
attached workers and the people
who aren't working full
time for economic reasons, the
difference is now 7.1%, so
that spread.
People who would like to work,
but they've either stopped
looking because they've gotten
dejected, or they've just
bitten the bullet and taken
a job that they otherwise
wouldn't want to take or taken
fewer hours than they
otherwise wouldn't want to
take, that's growing.
That really is.
And the reason why we really
want to focus on that is
because it tells us that even
though the unemployment rate,
the official unemployment rate--
that is increasing very
steeply and I'll show a graph
right here, this is actually
work Mish did, where he actually
shows that the spread
between U-6 and U-3 has been
increasing, and it's been
increasing at an accelerating
rate since last February.
That's actually shown right
here in this graph.
And he got this from his
friend Chris Puplava at
Financial Sense, so I want to
give him credit for it.
But you see here, U-6, this
is the broad measure of
unemployment that we talked
about right here.
That's increasing at an even
faster rate than the standard
unemployment measure.
And this green line right here,
this is actually the
difference between the two.
What's interesting about that
is this is kind of measuring
the percentage of the labor pool
that's getting dejected,
that's getting depressed.
So they're either getting
depressed or dejected and not
looking for work, or they're
just saying, you know what?
I can't get a job 40 hours a
week anymore as an accountant.
I will now go work part-time at
the local department store
or do whatever it takes to put
some food on the table for
their families.
In general, it shows the
level of desperation.
And if you look here, and this
is really interesting.
This is also from
Chris Puplava.
If you look relative to the
path, the last major recession
that a lot of people talk about
is the early 80's, the
double dip recession, and
even though the headline
unemployment rate-- let me
make sure I get the right
color-- the headline
unemployment rate here is the
blue line, that is still
a good bit below.
We peaked out there, and I
don't know what the exact
number is, but it looks like
about in the mid 10%.
Even though we're a lot lower
than that now, we're at 8.2%
right now, if you look at U-6,
which is the broadest,
that's spiked up.
Unfortunately, the data
for U-6 doesn't
go back before 1994.
They actually changed how a lot
of things were measured.
The official headline rate,
instead of calling it U-3, it
used to be called U-5, but it
was, for the most part, the
same measure, but that's
changed a little bit.
But U-6 did not exist before
1994 so, unfortunately, we
can't measure U-6 back then.
But a good, I guess,
pseudo-indicator for U-6 that
we do have more historical
data on is the number of
unemployed for more
than 15 weeks.
These are people who have been
looking for work, but 15 weeks
or more, they still haven't
found a job even though
they've been actively
looking for work.
And that, if you look at least
while we have U-6 being
measured, it has tracked that
broad measure quite well.
So if we can make the assumption
that U-6 is always
on that line or above it as it's
graphed here, which it is
so far, then U-6 in the early
80's was probably right around
where that line is now.
Maybe it was a little higher,
maybe it was up here.
But what this graph really
does convey is that that
broadest measure of unemployment
is already as bad
as it probably was in
the early 80's.
It's just that we don't
have that data there.
And if anything, those part-time
workers, because
they are employed, so in the
official unemployment measure,
they're actually making
the number look
a little bit better.
Here you had fewer people.
You were either employed
or you were unemployed.
If you're unemployed, you
made the number look
a little bit bigger.
Here you have a lot more
people who are kind of
in-between, but they
get counted in
the employed number.
So they're making the actual
reported official unemployment
rate a little bit lower
than is actually
the economic reality.
I think that's a really
important thing to realize
that you have this accelerating
rate of
desperation out there in the
economy and, if anything, it's
telling us that things are
getting worse, and it's
probably as bad as they've
been in some of the worst
recessions in history and
they're only getting worse.
And going back to where we
started this video, in terms
of capacity utilization and what
that might do to prices,
this tells us that labor
utilization is
low and going down.
What that tells us, is
that the price of
labor is going down.
And you've probably read
multiple news reports already
about how this is the first
time furloughs are big.
People are actually
taking wage cuts.
So you're already seeing
deflation in wages.
And when so much of our economy,
and even the basket
of goods in the CPI-- and I'll
do another video on that --is
service based, if you're seeing
deflation in wages,
that's another data point that
tells you, at least in the
medium term, we're probably
going to see further deflation
in prices as a whole.
See you in the next video.